To finish top three in a field at 20 you probably need about 40 to 50,000 Iowans
to get onboard.
So you say,
Hey,
do you,
do I think I can be present United States?
The threshold question is this,
can I get 40 to 50,000 Iowans on board with the idea that them and their family
members getting $1,000 a month is a good idea that that would actually help
improve their lives?
Well,
I'm sure it would help improve their lives and I'm sure they would agree with
you.
The question is what are the other thing you see?
I don't think most people are aware that this is coming.
And I think you educating people and explaining all these statistics and seeing
the forecast,
particularly from your position as a serial entrepreneur who has a deep
background in business and you have a deep understanding of this,
you're,
you're helping in a tremendous way by educating people.
But I think most people have,
it may be a logically,
but they have different concerns.
So how do you address these other concerns?
Like,
I bet if you polled people,
but what are the issues?
What are the issues in this upcoming 2020 presidential race that you know who's
going to beat Donald Trump?
How do you do it?
This is like on the democratic side.
The idea is like anyone but Trump,
right?
Yeah.
This is,
I mean they would be so happy if fill in the blank.
Tulsi Gabard you,
whoever.
On the Republican side,
obviously it's Trump unless someone comes along or he goes to jail.
Right.
Those are the two possibilities.
Yeah.
What of the other issues and that you feel that people are really concerned
about that you can perhaps shed some unique light on?
Sure,
so the,
the three big policy is I'm running on our one the freedom dividend because a
lot of Americans are seeing their paychecks not keep up with their expenses.
Number two is we need to get healthcare off the backs of businesses and families
and move towards a single payer system.
Medicare for all,
because as an entrepreneur,
it makes it harder to hire people.
When you do hire people,
you want to make them.
Contractors are not fulltime employees.
It makes it harder for people to start businesses because they're concerned
about keeping their health care for their families.
So we got to get health care off the backs of businesses and families and try
and make the economy more dynamic.
And we spent twice as much on healthcare as other countries do to worst results.
Like it's right now we're in like the worst of all worlds.
And the third thing is,
and I referenced my wife when I talk about this now,
my wife is at home with our two boys,
six and three,
one of whom is autistic.
And when I say is like what is her work valued at in GDP?
And then people think about and they're like,
I don't know,
and I'm like,
zero GDP like doesn't consider that actual economic contribution.
Uh,
and then I say we have to do is we'd have to actually evolve from GDP as a
measuring stick because it actually doesn't work for us.
It's almost a hundred years old.
We made it up during the Great Depression.
Self driving trucks are going to drive GDP way up,
but it's going to be very,
very bad for many people and communities.
So we have to actually change the measuring sticks to something that would
actually,
our economy work for us make,
make it so that the market serves us instead of all us being inputs to the
market.
Because if we're all inputs to the market,
we lose to robots and AI and hands down and it's not like it doesn't matter if
you were like a really conscientious,
hardworking truck driver or like a really lazy sloppy when it doesn't matter.
Like you know,
it doesn't matter if you were like a really diligent radiologist or like,
uh,
it doesn't matter.
So we have to shift the market's emphasis to actually fuel our wellbeing and
changed from GDP,
which is again,
this archaic measurement we made up to,
to things that would actually correspond to how we're doing things like health,
how childhood success rates,
environmental,
quantify that.
How do you,
how would you quantify that in a way that would be translatable to the average
voter?
Yeah.
So we have measurements for most of these things.
And,
and again,
if you look at our numbers right now,
you'd see,
it's like,
what?
Like how many people listening to this know that America is life expectancy is
declining for the last three years.
You know,
that to me would be like a pretty important measurement.
But you think that's because of,
is it cause of suicide?
Is it because of drug overdoses?
It because of obesity diet?
What is it?
The,
the two causes that people point to the most are that drug overdoses and
suicides have overtaken be hickey color deaths as,
as the most frequent deaths in the United States.
I didn't know that suicide was on it unless I knew that drug overdose said,
taken obesity with suicides of Ot overtaken obesity as well.
Suicides have overtaken,
uh,
car accidents.
I'm not sure about it.
I'm sorry.
I meant I'm at car accidents.
I misspoke.
So w w s car accidents used to be number one.
Yeah.
Suicides are higher than car accidents now.
So suicides,
drug overdoses,
and then car accidents or suicides and drug overdoses.
Like,
I think drug overdoses,
the number one,
number one,
and then suicides number two.
Wow.
Uh,
and so that's why life expectancy has declined for the last year and very much
likely there's at least some of the number of the suicides are related to
economic disparity.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
if you look at the suicide rate in it's particularly pronounced in 50 to 50 year
old,
50 to 54 year old white Americans,
which are the population.
And I mean,
you resemble that.
That's me.
Yeah.
That's you,
which resembles the population that right now is,
is reaching a point where they're like,
hey,
my job skills don't have any,
uh,
you know,
like utility and the marketplace.
And then they go home and they just like,
you know,
start looking around and being like,
what am I doing?
I mean,
it's,
it's really dark.
It's punitive,
it's punishing.
And we've put our citizens in this situation where we all see ourselves as
economic inputs,
what the market says we're worth is what we're worth.
And if we're worth less than it's our fault.
And so the next move is to say,
okay,
I guess you know this place.
There's no place for me here.
I don't mean to sound skeptical,
but I just don't believe that $1,000 in a month is going
to fix that.
It seems like that would be a good thing.
Certainly not moving in the wrong direction,
certainly moving in the right direction,
but it seems that there needs to be some sort of a massive rethinking of
civilization itself.
If you're going to have that many things that are going to be automated and that
many people that are going to be out of jobs and feeling that the world that
they prepared for no longer exists.
Yes.
It seems like we need a step further,
another move,
a 100% brother,
and that's one reason why the freedom dividends not like,
uh,
like,
that doesn't solve the problem.
Right?
The problem is fundamentally one of reconstituting means of structure,
purpose,
and fulfillment in people's lives,
particularly in men's lives.
How do we do that?
Right?
So one important aspect of that is to actually start measuring how we are doing
as a society and saying that's actually where we're trying to go.
So instead of using GDP,
using some sort of other quantifiable method of measuring health and happiness
and fulfillment.
Yes.
Levels of engagement with work,
uh,
mental health.
I mean you can,
we have measurements for that.
We are sophisticated enough to do that.
And then if we say then as president,
I'm going to be up there in 2021 being like,
oh,
here's the state of the Union and here's like the data and then we're going to
say you don't want to try and do,
we're actually going to try and move those measurements in the right direction.
So let's try and get drug overdoses down by 50% in two years.
Let's try and get our mental health up a little bit like in,
in these ways and then make it so that that person who was at home being like,
okay,
like,
you know,
like there's not a job for me.
I'm getting 1000 bucks a month.
That does not solve all my problems.
It takes the edge off,
but then we can hopefully start reconstituting what that person's,
uh,
purpose is in their community,
in their neighborhood.
And so one of the things that I'm going to point out is that if you pump 1000
bucks a month into that neighborhood,
it ends up creating a whole new realm of opportunities for the people in that
community.
Like some of that money goes to,
you know,
like youth leagues and churches and nonprofits and creates jobs right there in
that community.
One of the examples I use is like if you're in a town in Missouri with 50,000
people,
and let's say you really like to bake,
but starting a bakery is a dumb idea because people just do not have money in
that town to buy your big to goods.
But then I pumped $60 million a year into that economy and a lot of that just
circulates right there in that town.
Then if I start a bakery,
it's a good idea.
And I know if my bakery fails,
I'm not going to die.
I can at least go home and get my dividend.
And then if I go to other people and say,
hey,
you want to like help me out with this,
then they also think it's a better idea than they would have.
So the money is not the solution.
The money helps set the stage for the solutions.
So does the measurements.
So does if you,
cause right now if like you don't even know that your life expectancy is
declining and it's kind of hard to solve that problem.
So if you say,
look,
this is actually how we measure how we're doing.
And then you go in and say okay like local government,
Ngo,
entrepreneur.
Cause right now like our entrepreneurs don't,
none of our entrepreneurs are working on trying to make that dude's life better
right now.
You know,
it's like that that's not only do so much.
Most entrepreneurs are just trying to succeed.
I mean it's very difficult to start a business,
right?
And then they actually have it work out.
Well the idea that they're going to look out for truck drivers,
it's not realistic,
but it at least we can start moving ourselves in that general direction if we
start.
Because as a CEO,
you know this,
you make what you measure,
you're not measuring it,
you have no chance.
If you start measuring it,
you at least start to open up the chance.
But what you're saying is the most profound,
which is like we need to reconstitute and meaning for many,
many Americans.
And that's what,
to me the most destructive aspect of that.
You know,
again,
like the,
the mental health indicators and like the suicides and the rest of it is like
there's a real loss of meaning for many,
many people here in this country.
Well obviously we're talking about a large scale,
but if you go back to the time before trucks and truck drivers,
that was not a viable occupation.
It wasn't something people did,
but yet they still found a way to occupy their time.
Do you think that there needs to be some sort of an education and some,
some sort of a,
a method of explaining to young people in particular that you have to think of
something to do because most of the things that you think you can do won't
exist.
So we have to think of what are the other possibilities and be creative and do
something with your life that only a human being can do,
which is a really weird way to think about it because most of the things you
used to be able to thank that a human being could do for a living are now going
to be done by robots.
But I don't think,
I think there's a giant gap between the understanding that you have and the
understanding that the average person has,
and this could be a real problem and trying to expand this platform.
Well,
we have to,
to inform you.
I got to tell you though,
when I say this to people,
they're like,
that makes perfect sense.
It does make perfect sense that that's scary about it.